we're actually going to go right now um
into our vasectomy joining us from
Brooklyn is Dr Jacob kgen and his
patient Nick Moren hi
doctor hi guys
hello what a what a brave patient how
you guys doing we're feeling we are
fantastic Nick I got to ask you how are
you doing uh I'm doing good we've been
here a little while setting up so the
nerves are slowly settling which is is
good and um may I ask uh for a vasectomy
it's a local anesthesia that you use is
that correct yeah there's a few ways of
doing it but today we're doing it with
some local anesthetic so just this tiny
little needle that he already went
through and feels okay don't want to
speak for him but uh so yeah just a
little bit of local in a
nutshell didn't mean to do that I was
looking for a concise word
but what is a vasectomy in a
nutshell it's a little bit above the
nutshell but uh no so a vasectomy
is it's uh considered a permanent form
of contraception for men uh but
basically the vast difference are these
little tubes that go from each nut if
you will on the left and on the right to
the outside world so we find those
little tubes and we snip them now I we
Every Man's situation is different how
did you make the decision that vasectomy
was right for you um we have two
beautiful children we have a
three-year-old and 11-year-old and um
the last pregnancy for my wife was a
little more difficult than the first one
so we decided that um you know we didn't
want to have any more children and just
like your audience member I felt like um
it's one thing I can do to take the
burden off uh you know the the birth
control that my wife has been dealing
with for our whole marriage and Dr Jacob
are are there any risks associated with
getting of vasectomy so pretty much any
procedure that you have done anywhere
for anything has some risks uh vasectomy
risks are really small you know most
people will have a little bit of pain
maybe swelling maybe a little bit of
bruising um but the risks of infection
bleeding pain they're always there for
any procedure but there's really not a
lot of restrictions we say a couple of
weeks of no sex sorry uh
and uh about 3 months after we asked uh
for a Sean analysis to be done to prove
that the vasectomy took and everything
is okay okay well uh nick uh I hate to
break it to you but it's showtime okay
so Dr Jacob is gonna great great he's
going to get you into position yes Dr
Mariel my chief Urology resident here
with me hi dr's already aniz hi hi
thanks for having us today we're really
happy to be here are we We Ready is Nick
ready to go he's ready oh wow I guess so
there he is my god wow um now can I ask
you Nick really quickly what was the
last thing your wife said to you before
going into this room uh she just she was
very nice this morning she was like um
it'll be okay I know you're going to be
nervous uh so she was she was really
sweet this morning before that she told
me not to be a wimp but other than that
we're she was very nice oh
all right if you don't mind just
narrating a little of what's happening I
see some scissors out but I can't tell
if they're cutting um a human or a
gown I'm just getting my sterile gloves
on but we're just cutting the Gown
there's no scissors cutting skin we do
this with uh pretty small little Nicks
in the skin Nick good one um funny and
uh yeah it's uh usually you feel a
tugging some station um and but you
usually don't feel pain we already gave
him some local anesthetic so he should
be fine all right so Dr Jacob and his
chief resident Dr marela are going to
continue the procedure with Nick and we
are going to check in with you later
we'll be with you the whole time but
we'll give you a little break do what
you need to do and next we're going to
answer audience questions on all things
not only vasectomy but male
contraception and we'll be right back
good luck Nick Good luck Nick
[Music]
yeah